impostos vamos falar sobre palavras
sobre o poder das palavras você chave em
que ao contrário do clichê
as palavras são como vento eu acredito
tem plena convicção de que as palavras
não vão e vêm sem rumo nem propósito ela
está em carga afetiva elas têm
identidades
ela está em valores e no painel no
primeiro panela catarina frisou espeto
que as palavras podem ficar ao coração e
ter impacto na nossa vida e sabem que há
palavras que podem trazer alguns
equívocos algumas ambiguidades por
exemplo se eu vos disser jo é palavra
manga
vocês conseguem interpretar esta palavra
o que ela significa manga pode ser fruto
e pode ser parte peça de roupa é a minha
camisola não tem mangas hora como você
chave enquanto comunicamos uns com os
outros
a comunicação é feita de palavras que
não estão isoladas elas relacionam
sempre se então se o furacão meu armazém
lexical buscar um objetivo como diz
cozida ea língua é um sistema
computacional
vocês vão interpretar a palavra na índia
como parte peça de roupa não gostar de
cozida
ok mas se eu optar pelo diretivo maduré
automaticamente vamos pensar na palavra
manga como fruto certo e sabem que as
palavras podem também causar ambiguidade
em frase deus vos a vossa atenção para
este frágil mas não comigo
o pedro durante as férias só escreveu
cartas a rita
vou dar alguns segundos para processarem
esta frase
alguém consegue identificar mais do que
uma interpretação duas
dci acreditam que esta frase tem três
interpretações em português
e essa ambigüidade é desencadeada por
uma pão e vinho é tão pequena que é uma
palavra só consegue identificar esta
interpretação
durante as férias o pedro não escreveu a
juíza ana margarida sua rita coloque o
sufoco em rita é e sintaxe nos dizendo
que o componente indireto sua rita
segunda interpretação durante as férias
eu não escrevi outro tipo de
correspondência
sou cartas não estais não e mails
sócatas conseguem ver esta tesche
durante as férias e eu não fiz mais nada
não foi à praia não fiz porto não foi à
discoteca só escreveu cartas três
interpretações e estabilizado e repito e
gerada pelo vinho é só vim como é nossa
língua viagem favor você chave quem
português na língua portuguesa nós
também temos palavras um com glamour é
desculpa eu queria dizer encanto digam
se não a maior encanto em dizer que
espaha em vez de temas em dizer resort
em vez de estância oferece em dizer quer
virar minha casa é um barbie que o e
churrasco aparem que tem as unidades
churrasco estes consoantes portais
churrasco é esse
as palavras estrangeiras que todos nós
usamos diariamente trazem impacto e
doenças ao discurso
mas você chave muitas vezes podem ser um
outro pelo a comunicação como licença
todos os clientes compreenderiam esta
frase depois do briefing é necessário
fazer o diabo enfim para poder fazer um
correto falou é do projeto e garantir o
cumprimento cumprimento com o atenção ao
cumprimento de design
é a língua as palavras têm de ser como
um rio não como uma montanha é atenção
as palavras e glamurosas desculpa
encantadoras mas que muitas vezes podem
ser um embaraço 18 pelo a comunicação é
true pelo também são as palavras
difíceis complicadas que muitas vezes
outro péla o processamento ea
compreensão de linguagem
desculpem porque obstaculizará em vez de
complicado porque o ego do isaaa em vez
de piorar e no âmbito do desporto porque
se a assinar a bola e vez perceber a
língua não pode ser uma corrida de
obstáculos bom sabem que também temos
umas palavrinhas que podem manchar a
nossa imagem que podem tirar nos
credibilidade que podem fazer nos prever
em segundos em um relacionamento é um
bom negócio um emprego imaginem que uma
briga em um jantar romântico mercado
para hoje sábado à noite e um apaixonado
desde autofone já a onda gente vamos
jantar hoje e ela desligue não vou
tentar mais com ela não quer conhecer
imagine um candidato a um emprego quem
dei entrevista diz eu gosto tanto da
área criativa frio de graça é e onde
está não só que eles nos voto explicação
do pronome no meio do verbo no futuro
ídolo e nunca nem sinal
obviamente que eu deveria ter dito
fá-lo-ia de graça e teria conquistado o
emprego imaginem também a credibilidade
bom os média e não os me ver os mais
publicação social e infelizmente
muitas vezes não fazem um bom uso da
língua portuguesa e este estas frases
que vocês estão neste momento é observar
são erros e incorreções muito freqüentes
e digam por favor se concordam comigo
podemos ou não eu viajo vou usar a
seleção do plural os hora da comunicação
social imprensa rádio e televisão podem
ou não perder credibilizar do seu
público seus leitores dos seus ouvintes
dos seus telespectadores disseram que as
pessoas foram executadas no estádio eo
verba quase significa desenhar esvaziam
os passos evocou os espaços nas pessoas
e no âmbito do desporto mas o homem é
bas mais uma vez pedir desculpas gol
estão com moral elevada
sabe o que significa moral ética estado
de espírito e rural
deveríamos viver os jogadores para o
jogo de hoje à noite estão com um mural
elvado e agora uma incorreção freqüente
que passa despercebida hoje menos atento
é vítima foi abusada e neste momento
vocês vão perguntar
eis que sempre é e que se passa com ele
está tudo bem com esta frase não está
lembram-se de voz ativa voz passiva eu
vou pedir que sigam meu raciocínio voz
passiva só é possível com verbas que não
têm posição clássica frase o gatinho meu
rato rato foi me come pelo gato e eu fiz
o relatório sendo o relatório foi feito
com sandra o verbo de usar é um verbo
que tem uma proposição e tal como eu não
digo na frase ativa eu gosto de livros e
não não posso ter uma possível inibição
gostado com sandra impossível então o
verbo usar uma vez que tem uma
proposição eu não posso ser possível o
ônibus da mulher não posso ter esse vôo
e desculpem a mulher e abusada do homem
não posso possivelmente um tal do inglês
business em português não é possível e
trata se de uma incorreção sintática
imagine uma empresa que insistem em
dizer aos seus clientes
nós pretendemos ir de encontro às suas
expectativas
contra não a empresa pretende ir ao
encontro das nossas expectativas e
finalmente e por esta parte toca eu fui
aluna da faculdade de letras e acreditam
que quando ficar uma certificado de
habilitações o mesmo com quem esteve no
centro do à tarde
desculpem o chefe da repartição
científica que sandro horta vaz realizou
o seminário abaixo dos criminosos e o
diz a dona arlete no guichê é dona
arlete os meus seminários não conter
nenhum crime
desculpe o verde discriminar significa
absolver de um crime
o verbo que deveria estar aqui quero ver
discriminar significa se parar e claro
vamos terminar a inglesa há palavras que
tenha em sua unidade que tem carisma e
que podem ter um impacto tal que tocam
diretamente o nosso coração e nada
melhor do que contar um episódio um
episódio pessoal que aconteceu com um e
mail do meu estudo conta na parte final
desse mael estava esta frase este é uma
solução financeira que aumentará o seu
envolvimento com o movimento não é este
o meu banco eu atrai por razões óbvias
como a bem é eu fiquei a olhar para este
frase e pensar e se o meu estudo conta
que tivesse optado e vou passar o dia
positivo
em vez de voltar atrás vocês conseguem
ver a parte final o envolvimento com o
homem é imaginem que o gestor teria
optado pelo uso do poço se vos eu
esta é uma função financeira que o homem
terá o seu envolvimento com seu banco
eu poderia por hipótese causar em mim
algum impacto
é óbvio que eu vou brincar um carinho
mexe enfim o seu bem o meu banco
a 5 par deste banco
possivelmente o produto financeiro que
eu pretendia me apresentar eu pretendia
apresentar desculpa eu teria interesse
em conhecer as suas características às
suas propriedades porque uma palavrinha
apenas causou impacto em mim e este
apenas alguns algum exemplo
um exemplo é desculpa e vou terminar com
uma das minhas palavras favoritas que do
meu ponto de vista é faz bem é quem
articula e amil o look tori ao
interruptor é palavra obrigada agradeço
imensa vossa atenção espera não batam
palmas ainda que eu quero deixar de dois
desafios agradecimentos a vossa atenção
e 10 dois desafios o primeiro
leiam bastante o leão em leitura de
qualidade porque sabem que a comunicação
é feita de palavras e as palavras
localizamos no hemisfério esquerdo
a linguagem está localizada no
hemisfério esquerdo e se vivemos hábitos
de leitura e sofremos qualidade e se
esse é um maio por influência de
adquirirmos palavras para o nosso leque
ea comunicação têm como matéria-prima as
palavras leão imensa o segundo desafio é
este façam um bom uso e espero que
entendam esse trocadilho com a troca do
dia a dia tive nome faça um bom uso e
uso o bom das palavras e sejam fleet
muito obrigada